all right how can we do something
different here what the how about the
Dutch I have bad bad experience with the
Dutch here well let's go with this in
response to c4 I'll try this which is
the Albin counter gambit another one
that I could use a lot of homework I
could use a lot of studying with this
for an Alban counter gamba what's going
on with me playing gambits I don't know
okay
well interesting
what's the skill pair we just transpose
into how many of you are recognizing
this structure right here because what
we could be having if I take in white
recaptures it's kind of like a what it
is like in exchange French since the e
pawns are absent and then white almost
follows up with c4 and I don't know that
that's really something good
let me see if I take here's the queen
gonna recapture tonight let's see
Queen upon one or the other it is the
pawn and now I think I devised a plan
around the d5 square because I am
anticipating now what I am anticipating
that white will have an isolated Queen
pond as soon as this capture occurs
voila that's what we have so do I take
now no you don't take right now you wait
what are you wait for you might ask well
you wait for this guy to first
that way he has to go to squares before
he is right here now is a wonderful time
look at that little patience what does
that get you
it buys you a move and make your
opponent expend a move so now what this
has to be a pretty annoying pin so why
not go there why not you ask because of
tricks on f7 if I did this right away
Bishop takes pawn King takes Knight e5
basically TKO technical knockout I'd be
dead if I played Bishop here before I
had my rook in a position to defend f7
my king is not a good defender of the f7
square Queen here might be an
interesting move defending the knight
getting out of the pin putting pressure
on b7 putting pressure on f7 and
allowing for maybe in Knight to e5 move
that will need to be calculated though
because I do have possibilities for
snipping the night and then snipping the
pond I'm not sure how it all works out
okay now this dark square Bishop white
does one thing defends the knight so the
Queen is freed up but this Bishop now
being blocked in how can I take
advantage of this awkward placement of
the night I would like to have the
position open up I think c5 is a good
direction to be going in c5 why not
welcome exchanges even though I was
trying to maybe work against this
isolated pawn maybe I could shift gears
here I think I really unliking that
or am i what about night here I don't
like blocking in this pond mmm I think
that's right actually though Knight
takes pawn is the threat tonight is
still pinned if Queen b3 I have a good
response to that now that's another
reason why maybe knight c6 is good Queen
b3 Knight a5 and goodbye to the
LightSquared Bishop and there's also as
a follow-up a night before move to d5
one thing that kind of kept me from
playing c5 by the way is that I didn't
like after takes that I would have to
move my bishop again even though it's a
decent diagonal pointing right at the
king and actually maybe I could do one
better it's probably more than decent to
be on this same diagonal but I don't
know something felt a bit off and I'm
still I still have some thoughts of
trying to play against this isolated
pawn I'm seeing it as a liability in
this in this case here so unless there's
some attack against my king I think this
turns out to be a bit of a problem and
with this Bishop ok so breaking the pin
what is the bishop doing it's breaking
the pin what is it not doing there's not
as much pressure on f7 maybe now is a
time to reposition my Knights get my
Knight to d5 what can I be doing if I
take here no this works I could just
take this pone why did it take me so
long to see that and it's important to
know the follow up here the follow up
being that when I when the knight
captures I don't take on e to with my
bishop because of just Knight recaptures
and I'm down a minor piece for a silly
pawn but rather after Knight takes I
take with my queen and my queen is then
in a position to defend my Bishop so
we're seeing that right now Queen and
Knight defending the bishop and if the
knight moves the Queen's come off the
position is simplifying quite a bit I am
up upon in this
game and then we are going to shift
gears and hopefully have good technique
in the end game how to recapture queen
or night which one would you go with if
I go with to my Queen Queen here it
could be a bit uncomfortable for me I
don't like well no no no that's alright
if I don't take up the night I was
thinking I want to meet Queen to b3 with
Queen back here I'm gonna go with this
though in fact if the Queen plays here
I'll just play b6 and sure enough that's
where she goes doesn't she
let's do this that's how I'm gonna
defend and I can always play C 5 and
I'll be looking to do that a little bit
from now okay also maybe a flight square
would be good no let me do this let's
get this in my bishop is unprotected
flight square and hits the bishop so my
opponent is going pretty fast here about
how about I go fast too let's try this
my knight is free to move their knight
is not free to move I'm gonna play
Knight here something I be cautious
about placing myself in a pin and also
maybe possible Forks night here Bishop
takes here and then that night can maybe
go somewhere but I could take and be on
the Queen I think this is working out
here it's important actually a bit too
scary for a little bit too scary for me
because there's no need to work myself
into a pin so there's definitely a
cleaner way to go about converting this
and I'm not happy so far at all with
this technique not good again it might
be alright because I have this rook move
and
well actually I think maybe something
like this is needed so I just have my
rope defended now I can move my knight
and well now I think I come all the way
back here just so I could now move my
knight here 28 seconds I have to go
quickly here Knight to f6 we're gonna
have a bloodbath on this isse Evan
squared a lot of pieces will die right
here and let's go my knight is also
watching over for this this Queen h7
move bunch of trades tricky Knights
Queen and Knight be very cautious my
knight would like to be on f4 right now
let's maybe get him there maybe my queen
is tied to the defense of the night not
the greatest position of being sneak my
King over here so there's no Queen h7
stuff Queen trade tricky Knights okay
tricky night so I get this I'm winning
stuff now I'm on this night there's also
a check here if the knight blocked let's
come here hang on right here's the best
just want to take this clean trade this
pawn cannot be stopped can it a 7 well
that's a clock situation here just want
to do this clock clock clock clock clock
stop that pawn for moving and then I
could target it for point to those pawns
and move them fast
this other guy do not allow for
stalemate
okay it's the simplest way to do it I'm
not just doing it to be fancy with with
a different getting like a bunch of
Queens on the board it's just the
simplest way to do it and you avoid
steel me
okay good game let's back up here hit
the rewind flip the board and let's see
where there is an improvement so this is
not the most testing line and I don't
know how much more I could really add if
you did run with D takes E I just know
that if Wendy takes a is played the
black move is going to then be D for
making things uncomfortable for this
Queen night with foul up moves like
Knight to c6 I've also seen f6 thrown in
here just trying to facilitate more
development for black more rapid
development Night Out I've seen Bishop
bow I've seen Queen to d7 and even a
queenside castle this is the move to be
looking into I don't know that this is
so uncomfortable for black if anything
black is already equal I would think in
this position and maybe they're maybe as
white you were already feeling like yeah
you know this is a problem being that
you're in a pin the position has opened
up your dark square Bishop has seen
better days and there's pressure on this
point right away with knight c6 so this
is this is kind of tough you're having
to go back and you end up losing a pawn
but consider early on this capture right
here D takes E and then after a pond
push what is the move after that you
don't want to do III right away because
of Bishop b4 but I think there's this a3
move involved D takes e d4 you could
bring your Night Out to f3 right away or
I think um something with a3 maybe right
away is best one or the other maybe the
knight or maybe a pawn push I like the
knight move first not sure why exactly
just I guess for sake of development
there but
yeah do you take cd4 and go we'll just
try this line instead of III because I'm
viewing it as what what do we have it's
an exchange French and it's like after
the e ponds are off it's almost like
your last move you're now playing c4 and
that's not a so common